twenty-four-year-old Justino Santos was
at the concert when the shooting
happened she's probably one of the
people that was hoping for a fun night
and she joins us on the phone
Justina first we thank you for talking
to us because I'm sure you were still
shaking up shaking up what can you tell
us about what you saw and heard thank
you for listening to what I have to say
so pretty much what I saw what I heard
was about 20 minutes something whose
concert there was what everyone's saying
that firecracker noise like what you
hear on 4th of July you know and I'm
where I was standing I was on the lovers
facing the stage I was on the left side
the left wing I'm closer to the stage
and so we initially look over you see I
saw smoke going up in the air and just
when I was questioning it and then all
of a sudden I would say after hearing
that first initial fire cracking noise
about 10 15 seconds later Jason I'll be
insulting off the stage to the right and
after he bowls off the stage my
boyfriend grabs me and says let's go now
and we both all the way to the left for
those closest I guess excellent we could
find by then these other people kind of
kind of getting under sitting still and
understanding of what's going on and so
we we then hop to the front benches and
we just we started running these and
just II know you said it first at first
you didn't think anything about it you
saw the smoke and thought maybe it was
possibly part of the show because we do
know that he had some pyrotechnics so
how long did this gunfire last in your
opinion total length I would say I mean
it obviously it feels like this we for a
long time but I also have to say about
20 to 30 minutes here there'd be around
and then there'd be a slight pause and
you can hear the screenings and then
another round unloading and what it
sounded like was there was multiple
multiple shooters but what it really was
was just ten but unloading 131 unloading
one did you see people being hit by
gunfire as you and your boyfriend were
escaping
thankfully I did not
I was on the left side facing the stage
and the people that were unfortunately
injured are shot we're on the right side
of the stage and immediately once we
heard it and our instinct jumps up and
we went we just went east we knew cuz
I'm some Vegas so I knew you know I mean
we could hear and see and we just some I
guess our instincts just told us where
to go just you know we're there any when
you go to the concert or arrive there
I'm not sure if you've gone to this in
the past where there are our exits
marked are there is it explained where
how you're supposed to go in and get out
of the concert yeah I did it on this
same concert last year there's a clear
entrance for people there so everyone
knows where to enter there's one
entrance and exiting I think they do it
kind of differently over here there's an
exiting on one end of the wrong
lengthwise of the strip on the left on
the far left side and then I'm not sure
if they and then they they do let people
off at where you enter so there is
normally a separate entrance and exit
for people
Justina one thing we have heard
throughout this morning is the the
humanity and people helping people not
just the first responders whose job it
is to run in and help those who were
wounded but concert goers there
Samaritans who were helping others did
you see that as well and can you
describe what you saw
yeah I definitely saw a little bit of
both I saw people frantically throwing
no panicking and then I saw people that
were hoping for example my boyfriend I
we jumped we had a jump several senses
and where we were jumping the fences
where the vendors where the food vendors
so there's actually a hot stove on one
end and then there's a boiling we're
going grease on one side so it's really
crazy so I'm yelling at people don't
watch out for the grease it's right
there this stove is hot if you're trying
to get on the so if you jump over the
fence and then before you know it
there's a guy I'm lifting up a girl over
the fence the guy's lifting up me over
the fence my boyfriend's helping
somebody over the fence and so
definitely people you know people just
one two three you know what I mean
everybody trying to
watch the fake thing getting to safety
Justine if you've been another you've
been other concerts or outdoor festivals
in that area it was actually out life is
beautiful last weekend so yeah I was at
Isis beautiful last weekend also
iHeartRadio was in that same village
where route 91 was taking place last
weekend there's a ninja warrior show has
been filmed at that scene Fairgrounds
for round and you wanna so yeah I
definitely have and so for people
unfamiliar with where that actually is
and where these festivals take place can
you talk about the area it's just a
great big open area where there's drinks
food great music going on good people
you know you just go and you look your
best and you try and have fun and just
have a great time so it's it really a
wide and it's open and there's different
things you know what I mean walking off
certain areas or vendors or certain
sections for people that are selling
food so it's definitely just big open
areas and that did you have any concern
Justina did you have any concern being
in a big open area you know
unfortunately we have heard stories
about shootings at concerts we know
ariana grande there was an explosion in
Paris there was a shooting as you went
to a country music festival did you have
any concerns at all about your safety
did you find yourself looking around
before the concert began or no no ma'am
I did not
Jake Jay Cohen joined us a little
earlier today and he said listen I'm
just a guy who sing songs and writes
music he intends to get back on the
stage he said we can't let this deter us
and live our life how are you feeling
about that are you thinking that you
would feel safe going to another concert
are you still processing at all I would
say I'm definitely still processing at
all my cars unfortunately parked at
Excalibur and so it's still there and
I'm kinda a little weary right now
thinking about having to go back in pick
it up but I don't think that this
incident and this sadistic degree should
to tear any of us from you know the
means doing what we do best which is
coming together for one single thing
which is music or
or whatever they whatever the occasion
is you know which it shouldn't because
run and hide in a hole it should
definitely bring us all together just
seem to be doing that where are you
right now I am at home I live in Las
Vegas off of Silverado ranch and Justina
a lot of us know of Las Vegas is a
transient city a place where people go
for a few days for a concert for a
conference
Las Vegas is home for you talk about
what this means for something like this
to happen in your hometown and and how
does this town how does this city
recover and heal and start the healing
process obviously this is just hours old
right I fortunately been going living in
Vegas for the past few years they go
into graduate school at UNLV and just
going forward from this like I said you
know we all have to pick together a
metro I think is doing a great job
keeping us informed of whatever they
know they let us know I've been watching
the news non-stop since the incident so
it's feel like there's been a lot of
camaraderie yes and I mean this
togetherness you know everyone's just
coming together so that's been pretty
awesome to see and I think that in
itself and working together is what's
gonna let Las Vegas Nevada and general
come up on top over this horrific
incident all right Christina thank you
very much for taking the time to talk to
us today we really appreciate you
joining us this morning and we're glad
you're okay
Justina Santos is her name 24 year old
college student